Making a web app work offline or
have amazing performance on slow
networks used to be extremely hard.
But service workers changed that.
I've asked Jake Archibald to
explain service workers for us.
Jake, take it away.
>> Service workers is a JavaScript realm
execution context in an environment
settings object with its own event
loop and node document dependency.
Unlike similar context,
which is shared workers, this context's
life cycle is dictated by life cycle and
functional extendable events and
their associated array of
extended life cycle promises.
Although, the user agent may apply
a grace period to avoid startup shutdown
overhead between events.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> Okay, that made no sense.
Let's try this from a different angle.
A service worker is a JavaScript
file that is run by your browser
in the background,
separate from your webpage.
And handles events fired either
by the browser or your webpage.
Since it's run in the background it
doesn't need the webpage to be open.
And it doesn't show any markup.
Where it really shines is
the events that it can listen for.
One of the most exciting is
the ability to handle fetch events,
intercepting and
responding to network requests.
This puts the service worker virtually
between the network and the browser.
Allowing the service worker to
provide content even when offline.
Because the service worker can listen
for an event, even when the page isn't
open, they can respond to push messages
sent from the server to the browser.
Imagine a chat web client that let's you
know you've got a new unread message.
This simply was impossible before.
In the future, service workers will
support other things like periodic sync,
geofencing, and more.
In the past, you could have
tried using app cache to try and
make an app work offline but
it was a pain.
There were too many gotchas and
it didn't have the power or
flexibility that service workers brings.